I could have you on the program so
Kristan was calling for an election why
is now the time
because I don't think there's any cure
for this chaos under the current
government what the last few days have
shown us is not only lots of things we
already knew about Boris Johnson and how
he'd blame everybody else for his
downfall but the way that he attacked
which is anakiness he first of all used
and played Rishi soon act to get
approval for this honors list that he
wanted before he went but then in that
resignation statement that he made on
Friday he has attacked a number of
policies around not having a trade deal
with the United States
post-brexit policies the tax position
but he's also attacked which is your
next future strategy he said that if
Rishi sunak and Jeremy Hunt bring in
pre-election tax cuts it'll be seen
through as a gimmick so he's not only
attacking Rishi present he's attacking
Rishi future too and the conclusion is
this is not over it's going to continue
it's not that surprise thing is that
where you know one of your predecessors
attacks you I mean look at the
relationship between kirst armor and
Jeremy corbyn this is nothing new is it
they're the party of government and if
this goes on the chaos will continue
you've got Jacob Reese smog one of Boris
Johnson's principal allies writing in
one of the Sunday newspapers today that
not only should Boris come back but he'd
be a good candidate in a future
leadership election so it's quite clear
this is going to continue in the
conservative party and they cannot fix
it themselves the only way to fix this
is to have a general election and a
change of government otherwise the
country is going to be bedeviled by this
chaos and instability and it's having a
real effect on the governance and the
economy of the country there'll be some
elections uh pretty quickly three
by-elections coming up including of
course the Boris Johnson's overseas in
Oxford has labor got a real chance
yes I I think we I think we have we're
going to fight all of these by-elections
to win there are no no-go areas for the
labor party and I think that these
violations can be the first step towards
removing the government uh that's the
message that we'll be giving to voters
uh in those constituencies and we're
going to fight all of them hard we're
going to fight all of them to win we
just heard from katihari who was talking
about the Privileges committee and
saying that look he understands why
Boris Johnson Fields handed out by a
committee that was led by Harriet Harman
of course the leading figure in the
labor party Forrest Johnson has
described it as a kangaroo court do you
understand why some closer Bros Johnson
feel that what's happened is a bit
undemocratic you know he won a landslide
he was elected in Uxbridge why is it MPS
who are forcing them out this is Trump
like on both sides of the Atlantic uh
the statement that he made apart from
the parts which attack Tracy sunak rate
left and Center on Friday we're all
about him avoiding responsibility for
his own actions he's got a record of
trying to trash institutions in his own
interests that's what he was doing on
Friday the committee has a conservative
majority he's got a conservative
majority that's really important for
viewers to understand also the
committee's verdict isn't the last word
it then goes to Parliament where the
Tories are sitting on a majority of
around 66 seats at least it was on
Friday before they all started resigning
and even then it just triggers a recall
petition where he could face the voters
the truth is he didn't want to face any
of the verdicts because he can never
accept responsibility for his own
actions and that's true of all these
right-wing populist leaders they're like
baby men whenever anything goes wrong
it's everybody else's fault that was the
characteristics in the statement on
Friday and it just revealed to us that
party can't resolve this on its own
right we've talked an awful lot about
Boris Johnson let's talk about some
other things shall we uh you've done
some analysis on mortgages which to be
honest is something that I know many of
our viewers they're going to be really
genuinely quite worried about what have
you found we found that compared to two
years ago uh interest rates have added
some seven thousand Pounds a year to the
average uh mortgage bill and the thing
that really boosts the Rockets under the
mortgage rates was the conservative
disastrous mini budget uh last September
that's when markets lost confidence in
the UK that's when the Tories shredded
any reputation for economic stability
and responsibility that they had and
people are paying the price for that
every month as their previous two or
five year rates that they've been on
come up it's not just that though is it
like I I accept that you know what
happened in that mini budget was a
pretty disastrous for the markets but
look it's also about other things isn't
it like Global High inflation as well
and I guess my point is rather than
looking at the causes of it what was
Labor going to do about it you've
identified the problem what's your
solution well first of all it's a big
part of that that really good solution
the solution has to be Financial
stability for the long term uh that's
what we want to ensure uh the lesson
from uh the experience last September
should be that we any future government
has to put Financial stability first uh
has to make sure that it matches
ambition with responsibility and that's
what will characterize our approach
um I just wonder the responsibility
argument the financial stability if that
comes into the debate that is going on
around this 28 billion pound a year that
labor wants to spend on green energy now
there's been lots of talk this week
about Labor rowing back from the plan
but as far as I can tell you're not
really wearing back from are you you're
saying that you are going to end up
spending 28 billion a year on green
energy but just not immediately well two
things have changed since we announced
this plan A couple of years ago first of
all the economic situation that we're
talking about we've had 12 interest rate
risers we've had the experience of that
uh Tory mini budget last year and that
has underlined the need for financial
stability but my point is just doing it
okay you're not doing it year one but
that was never going to happen was that
you're still saying that you are going
to end up spending 28. the second thing
the second thing is really important
it's also changed in the last two years
which is in every conversation that
we've had with uh investors and
businesses we've discovered a real
thirst for private sector investment in
this too and we've also had the
experience of the inflation reduction
act in the United States and that's been
not just about what government does but
about crowding in the private sector
investment so I don't think the right
lens to look at this through is just
what government borrows and invests an
essential part of of that this is it's
also about what you can do in
partnership with a private sector we've
got a big long-term plan for this it's
also a responsible long-term plan and it
can lead the country through a change
that is going to happen it's an awful
lot of money though isn't it 28 billion
every year and there's all going to be
all sorts of departments who are going
to be looking at this saying hang a
minute I need to build more homes I need
to invest in schools and hospitals 28
billion you could knock a billion off
that and say it was a surrounding error
is then miliband his policy is he going
to cost you another election
look this is an ambitious policy there
are always trade-offs and choices uh in
government but the announcement that we
made on Friday said one very important
thing to the British public which is
that we will match our Ambitions with
responsibility we will also match them
by crowding in private sector investment
that's the best way to do this to lead
the country through a big change so that
when it comes to the election we're much
in realism with hope and that's the
right approach uh just finally
um there have been some allegations uh
claims made about MPS in the labor party
and behavior that they have allegedly
been part of and most recently labor
Shadow Minister bambo sherylambers
suspended over a complaint I don't want
to get into the details because
obviously there are two sides to every
story people deserve a fair hearing
but is a labor party really serious
about behavior in Westminster and
rooting anything out that is improper
yes we are
I mean like you I don't want to get into
an individual case but I've worked
around Westminster for a very long time
both as an MP and previously I worked in
number 10. you know I want this to be a
place where both politicians and the
many staff members who who work there
can come into work excited about what
they're doing working in public service
whether they're working for the
governing party or the opposition party
and be confident that it's a great place
to work so I'm saddened when I see these
allegations they should all be properly
investigated but let's make sure that
Westminster is a good place to work and
embodies the best of Public Service okay
thank you very much indeed